hey reject nation
Greg Alba John I've heard that this
boobies been getting backlash we got a
couple of requests for it and I don't
care check it out because I don't really
care for Amy Schumer to begin with I've
not seen much of her stuff and all I
knew was this trailer exists this is all
new to me I have no idea what goes on or
the specifics as to why it's been
getting a lot of hate I saw a movie clip
site that this had like a grab that it
is like I was using the bathroom before
Black Panther started the other day and
then I came back and my girlfriend was
like oh my god I just saw that Amy
Schumer trailer I was like oh would you
think she's like tell me what was wrong
with it but I liked your watches and
what more appropriate video to shout out
James stay Gonzalo James then I feel
pretty video sometimes I watch stuff
where there's a lot of backlash and I'm
like I don't really agree with all that
but let's let's see cuz I have no idea
what and you've already got an opinion
from somebody whose opinion you
understand yeah yeah wait sometimes
disagree she likes me
[Music]
okay here in the solution
[Music]
I have so many questions do you get it I
have a theory as to why ruins is that
part of it is it like take some kind of
mind altering delusion to make her feel
sure and yet though she gets her head
hit to think that she's beautiful and
the whole people going why are you so
confident I'm not attracted to Amy
Schumer but I'm not gonna say she's
hideous or ugly to begin with she's a
pretty person yeah yeah she has a more
nor like a different physique I guessed
and we're used to seeing from the lead
in this kind of movie they're making a
point to acknowledge that she's you know
yeah at least a little I get why people
are not on the side of the camera going
oh man I'm offended because I'm not a
woman who's had to deal with these
issues but I can see how women would
find this very offensive and the fact
that she's being mean to herself doesn't
necessarily compensate for any vacation
can also go wrong being just a kind of a
weird geek show of some kind because
it's also being kind of mean about like
even when you're seeing her and she's
dancing yeah
he's got a little bit of extra way but
she still has like have muscles and
stuff it's kind of fat shaming in a way
when you're not it's not even now she's
n even fatties you know I mean I can't
tell what this is dude yeah I can't I
can't tell and that's not very good and
I can't tell if it's the trailers fault
I can't tell or if it's the confusing
tone of a movie because parts of me go
like that dance scene on stage I'm like
okay I go they're shooting you like they
would shoot any like wash for supers
like they Shia Jennifer Aniston and we
are they're like they're gonna do that I
see what could come out of that that
could be positive but yeah there's
something there's like a weirdly
repelling vibe about some of this
trailer and it is just a trailer too so
it's like I can't tell where this
movie's heart is it's a reverse Shallow
Hal and if this movie had more of the
message that whatever the dude is that
she's dating in here if it hones in on
that too mean-spirited type of comedy
like I said reverse Shallow Hal which is
a very mean-spirited type of comedy
where a guy has to learn by the end that
it's not what counts on the outside of
what counts on the inside here it seems
like that's what that dudes trying to
convey to her is like it's really about
confidence and your confidence is what
makes you attractive and stuff I feel
like that'll be the ultimate message but
the joke and and the fact that it is a
trailer is honing in on like the message
that it can communicate this isn't
attractive and it's why I think she's
attractive with this yeah well that's
not the case and that's mean to a lot of
women that's it yeah again I wonder what
the actual movie looks like because
chaid they're bad trailers for stuff
although I don't even think a more
Schumer is that funny
honestly I've tried watching some of her
stand-up bits more than I have her
actual films yeah other than that one
good movie she didn't really like
anything else and that's the other thing
I'm wondering too is I feel like
trainwreck had at least a bit more of a
grounded feel right like yeah there's a
gen happy town about and she's also lost
as Russia known to that I've lost a lot
of weight and she she's a lot more fit
here than she ever was
she's muscular here like she actually
has muscles wait so she goes which is
just yeah which is like messed up if
this was like pre Amy Schumer where she
was just
a huge and that was the jobber like Oh
Amy sure we're making fun of herself now
it were like she really hones in there
but now that she's more fit now she's
kind of just regular-sized to me now
well yeah so now it's kind of like it's
a shaming of body image that's the
ultimate sourness of this whole trailer
is the it feels like the movie itself is
going it's not true though that's a
bummer
that is a very real crisis to have to
like want to embrace yourself want to
try on that confidence but secretly
you're like it's not true though that's
the thing people feel but yeah I don't
know something about the heat this
trailers tambour the fact that she had
to get like get hit on her head in order
to think that she's pretty is kind of
funny that's the that's a promise like
it doesn't feel funny I feel like there
is a what-if to be had there about like
well what if you know something happened
where you could immediately see the OP
that kind of confidence and what could
that teach you like I get why that could
be a good setup for something just the
way that it's handled in this trailer
anyway it makes it feel like yeah like
why does it take this like weird
mind-altering thing for her to be able
to conceive that she might not be yeah
and then for the whole movie to be like
nah dude you bumped her head that's
what's going on yeah there's no Johnny
to your character for real like I'm not
attracted to her but I can I can
acknowledge it she's pretty though she
never struck me as the kind of girl who
would strike out all the time or some
point that you know it's Amy Schumer
she's a more regular who's your odds but
she's a more regular girl than like a
megan fox or a Jennifer Aniston and that
this is a good opportunity because we we
should have a movie in this shelf of the
store of the video store I just don't
know if this one's gonna be it and
that's a real bummer because the stuff
that this hints at trying to take on is
worthwhile and it's the time to do it
you know this all comes down to
execution hey man that would be a fun
turnaround if he wants that movie
picture the day shout-out though hey for
james Sagan's i hope you know how
beautiful i hope you know how beautiful
you are buddy don't hate if you don't i
suggest jumping off of your roof
smashing your head on the concrete that
way to rearrange your whole physique and
then you would think that's prettier and
i hope that you can see how pretty are
honestly james you have a very beautiful
soul when it's all said and done it's
much easier for guys to get hot girls if
they're good on the inside that's the
sad part about life is you can see many
an ugly guy with a beautiful girl so it
doesn't even matter if you feel pretty
just be a little confident and you could
get a hot piece of thing you know I made
peace of thing and I know you like
yourself some Amy Schumer I know that
she's a girl that you really like so
she'd go out there and go bag yourself
an Amy Schumer hangout and open mic
night yeah man
subscribe to get updated every time a
reviewer videos out patreon we just
shouted our page from we got a bunch of
cool patrons over there and exclusive
content come join us
full-length music videos TV shows we
even did a movie commentary for that
Cloverfield [ __ ] that just happened it's
alright yeah you have to get hit on your
head to feel pretty James